[Music]
legendary director and writer Oliver
Stone is known for his award-winning
movies like born on the 4th of July
platoon and Midnight Express over his
career the filmmaker has also
interviewed controversial figures like
Hugo Chavez and Fidel Castro or his
latest documentary The Putin interview
Stone was granted extensive access to
the Russian president Stone interviewed
Putin more than a dozen times over two
years no topic was off limits in a
conversation from February 2016 Stone as
Putin about the candidates in the United
States presidential election
but you do realize how powerful your
answer could be if you said subtly that
you preferred ex candidate
he would go like that tomorrow and if
you say you didn't like Trump or
something right what would happen he'd
win right you have that amount of power
in the U.S
house
state two
Oliver Stone is with us now in his first
television interview about the
documentary good morning good morning
Charlie you had a extensive opportunity
to take an evaluation of Vladimir Putin
former Secretary of Defense Robert Gates
once said of him when I look at him I
see a cold-blooded killer when you look
at him after these two years what do you
see
you're asking for a full full
understanding of somebody who I spent 20
hours filming 20 hours of film and he
reveals himself more in the film than
anybody I've ever seen and how does you
have to I'd like you to be that you know
if you think he's still a killer after
you see these 20 minutes a cold-blooded
one and so forth that's fine you know
you draw your own conclusion I'm talking
about what Robert Gates said I'm not
talking about what I said do I agree
with Mr Gates yeah well no what do you
see in other words that's what gate saw
what do you see having spent this time
with him
a Statesman who's very concerned with
the Russian national interests he's
represented those same interests pretty
consistently since about 17 years in
power
and he's there to talk he believes in
talk he believes in peaceful coexistence
he said in the whole two years I never
heard him badmouth anybody
you know talking about those candidates
you know he said very positive things
about Hillary Clinton
and positive things about Trump but he
never he displayed any names he didn't
care about who would win in fact if you
look at the fourth hour I think you've
seen the fourth hour he says very
clearly you know the presidents I've had
four presidents the four presidents
change the policies remain the same you
sort of act as if you take what he says
is fact
well let me I'm in an interview on why
should he lie you know if he if he is
why should you admit something I mean I
can understand if it's a state secret I
mean the clip you just played unlike
many partners of ours we never interfere
with the domestic affairs of other
countries I mean that's a flat out lie
if you say so I'm not sure I mean I'm
not here to argue with you but I'm not
there to you know to make why do you
think he granted judgments on whether
they hack the election or not it's it's
a complicated issue why do you think he
granted you such extensive access
because you interviewed him over 20
hours 20 hours of film it was quite a I
got to know him in the Snowden movie
because I was interviewing Snowden in
Moscow and uh we went over nine times
actually the seasonal to get the story
right and when I was there one of those
times I actually met him I asked him
about this no no fair he filled me in
it's quite brilliant about his point of
view about it and we said one thing led
to another but but back to Nora's
question though Oliver the access you
had you were in his house he was driving
you around in a car you went to the gym
with him you sat down and you ate with
him how were you able and allowed to
have such access to him
maybe I'm a good interviewer maybe
people like me you know Gail it's it's
not easy to say I mean I think did you
just ask him that you said okay no no he
was inviting us if I think he wanted he
knew that he'd be heard fairly because
I'm not going to be an editor on this
thing I'm going to let him speak and his
point of view is not hurt you don't hear
him in Russian in the west right you
always hear it I mean you hear a dumb
voice and sometimes a dub voice can be
very harsh no he says his theory of life
is summed up in the philosophy of Judo
that he's taken Judo since he was 11. be
flexible be disciplined is that what you
found him to be just totally unfair I
never saw I mean he he works out every
day yeah and he is he learned hockey at
62 or something like that he's playing
now two years later he's a sportsman but
he's disciplined and flexible at the
same time that's what Judo taught him
dude never saw him lose his cool with us
I mean a few times I pushed him more
than once and I saw him get rattled and
upset but you know I have to continue
this relationship it's my in my interest
to encourage him to speak so Charlie did
one with him too was very effective yeah
thank you um I asked him a number of
things including whether he's a czar
President Obama once said about him
there's hardly anything that goes on in
Russia that he doesn't know about or is
not responsible for
I'm not sure about that Charlie you know
Russia's a huge country with 11 time
zones there's an old saying you know the
Czar the Czar is Acts were able to be
executed about one-third of them were
you know by the time he gets down to the
Providence level and the village level
Moscow is a long way away the U.S
intelligence agencies believe that in
fact Russia didn't meddle he's alluded
to it said might not have been the
country but somebody in Russia might
have done it yeah uh Patriot might have
done it um don't you I mean talk to him
having made a measurement of the man and
being in Russia have some sense of and
knowing America will have some sense of
whether the Russians meddled in the
election I don't know Charlie I you know
why would they I mean there there's you
know Miss Clinton is his way in the lead
you know why would you even take the
position that Trump is is going to be
your candidate he didn't look like he
was going to win that was quite a shock
you know I'm of the beliefs that she she
did not win she did not run a very good
campaign and you know there were a lot
of on the on the footprints on the
digital Footprints there's a lot of
confusion the Intel agencies people that
was not an estimate that was an
assessment just to be just to clarify it
is the consensus of all U.S intelligence
agencies that they attempted to meddle
in the election it is symptoms that they
influenced the outcome which I think is
okay there's no yeah so those are two
those are two separate things right
those are two separate things can I ask
you though because the Russians are
involved in not only meddling in foreign
countries but they're involved in
propaganda efforts as well foreign
policy wrote of your documentary some it
somehow manages to both spout the
Kremlin line and fall back on the
laziest American cliches about Russia
another said you gave him a love letter
to Vladimir Putin with this documentary
irresponsible you catch what your mom
used to do you know you catch more flies
with honey than with vinegar and my
camera was on him for we're on 20 hours
over
four visits you you there's a certain
Behavior it's in the eyes it's in the
body language and I you see it and you
make it I hear you be the judge if you
think he's lying I yeah well I think the
most important thing we can say about
this is first of all he's an interesting
figure on the world stage today number
one number two or whatever else he is
he's a strong nationalist I mean he
believes in Russia and some say he wants
to have influence Beyond Russia thank
you and I do think you give us a
extended Glimpse that we would not see
of him yeah no we can only learn from
this different settings and he wants to
be our partner he said very positive
things about the United States he talks
about the partnership it's been a long
time he knows the presidents we should
listen it's fascinating Oliver thank you
thank you for the interviews premieres
tonight on Showtime a division of CBS